you
by travelpod member
Oh
you
travel not civil oh hey look we're gonna
start now Craig yeah
again mommy
I can
Oh
from idle
enrique is on
so I'll open that afterwards
so we're going to get underway if you
can grab your seats
hey are you
okay welcome everybody it's a beautiful
New York day it's also very strange day
for me because you're all wearing this
very odd costume it's really strange
that you're wearing this because
students are coming to the school from
more than 50 different countries
completely different kind of people with
completely different kind of interests
and directions and the kind of mantra of
the school is a kind of biodiversity in
a complexity and then suddenly you're
all in this uniform and it's very
confusing to me in theory there's no
uniform for the school there is nothing
you could wear that would fully
represent what the school was about
there's also it's a very strange outfit
that you wearing because it hides you
there's just a little face left you also
all of you look younger than normal
which is very strange you have a kind of
innocent look the problem is that I know
you and you're not innocent at all so
it's a weird moment I mean in in the
school there is nothing hidden there are
very very few secrets as you know and in
fact the whole point of the school is to
open things up for new kinds of
inspection new kinds of vision new kinds
of thinking and sometimes a little bit
embarrassing what you see when you open
things up maybe that's what architects
do they take hold of the everyday
environment and they create an opening
they create a way of seeing it different
architects are responsible for one or
two percent of the build fabric in the
world so the main role of the architect
is to take advantage of the one or two
percent and use that one or two percent
to change everybody's attitude so in
other words you you you you use design
as a kind of as a kind of a weapon to
change the way people think I think the
greatest gift of an architect is simply
to to have people hesitate during the
routine of their life that they stopped
for a moment they see things a little
bit different and in seeing it different
that maybe can think different and if
you think different you could live
different and if you live different
maybe society changes so the designer is
always a super super ambitious person
that thinks that you make the small
change and there could be a very big
philosophical change what's interesting
about this is that you you are all
absolutely united in in your kind of
optimism which makes no sense at all
because if you look at the newspaper or
what used to be called the newspaper
it's not good the world is not in great
shape we have invented every possible
way of doing things stupidly and the
university is the place to be not so
stupid so here's the situation you have
a world which is being more and more
stupid and you have a university trying
to understand what it can can do with
that and I think that this optimism that
you have this belief that we could live
in a better society is unbelievably
precious is sort of super super valuable
and it is what you have to to to offer
in other words all you can do is show
people the world differently so you're
very much with the artists in this
respect that you open up new forms of
perception it's amazing to me that you
survived the school absolutely amazing
it's even more amazing to me that we
survived you because we are really quite
expert at inventing impossible
assignments and you have become experts
at kind of making that seem easy you're
a generation that is a superior species
the multitasking multi-touch generation
you're the first generation that in
architecture and urban design that
refuses to accept compromise there is a
normal way of thinking which is the real
world makes you compromise and
university makes you
sort of innocent and and optimistic and
romantic and utopian but you are really
the generation that in the world refuses
compromise so there is this strong
feeling now that cities can be beautiful
socially responsible energy responsible
that you can make a lot of money that
you can be an artist and a scientist
that you can have your own NGO in fact
increasingly you have to get an NGO
before you admit it to a school of
architecture so we're in a completely
different age and you are a different
generation with a whole new set of
skills and capacities we really try to
make life horrible for you and I'm very
frustrated that we didn't succeed that
you still more or less happy the good
news is that I think you are going to
make things horrible for the people in
the world you are going to be a lot of
trouble because you have a way of
changing perceptions and there can be
nothing more powerful than then
communicating another way of seeing and
thinking you will for sure transform
your fields I think architecture and
urban design will will simply not be the
same in a very short period of time of
course this change doesn't happen
immediately you are for sure
heat-seeking missiles and what's not
clear is when you explode the
conventional wisdom is five years later
so you return to your 50 different
countries and there's a small kind of a
ticking sound and then after five years
there's an explosion and your field has
changed and what's interesting also I
think you are also the first genuinely
globally interconnected generation so
you are the first global think tank so
each of you will assume a kind of
professional relationship to the world
and you'll have a very specific
situation and a very specific mission
but for the first time you will have you
will be surrounded by each other as
colleagues in other words you will you
will be operating in a more global sense
and these kinds of things used to be
platitudes this used to be kind of
comments about the global village since
the 1960s on but now it's the reality of
that and
think you really are the first
generation that will bring to bear on
very precise local situations a kind of
global interactive real-time
multi-dimensional multitasking expertise
we really have no idea what you're going
to do zero idea remember that you chose
this school of architecture because we
don't know what the future is even
though we've been with you for four
these last years we still don't know
what you will do in fact we know even
less now what you will do when you came
in and that's why we know you're a
fantastic year you of course are the
secret of the school the students are
four thousand perhaps five thousand
times more interesting than the faculty
that's obvious we try to make the
faculty stronger stronger stronger so
that it makes it more and more difficult
for you to show how superior you are but
you make it very very easy you really
are something special also you are the
post professional program so you have
this amazing mix of real-world
experience and expertise and the kind of
totally experimental vision that comes
in a experimental school like G SAP and
I think this combination of realism and
experimentation is another defining
feature of our time it used to be that
our school was so experimental that it
was 10 to 15 years before the
experiments done at the school became
the new reality of the profession almost
the reverse is true today that in order
to be a successful professional the
world is changing so fast a city can go
from 1 million to 10 million people in
five years more than fifty percent of
the world's buildings are being built in
China at an incredible speed so you're
living in a world that changes more
quickly than any university so to be
professionals you will have to be
experimental you will need to have a
kind of a research capacity so what's
super interesting about your generation
is probably you're the first generation
in which the radical experience of a
laboratory school will be exactly the
professional expertise that you will
bring to bear
whole parts of our world like Latin
America Africa South Asia East Asia what
used to be Russia and so on these are
enormous laboratories in which you will
operate and you will operate probably
even with a more experimental mode of
behavior than you had at the school so
we've left behind an old model which
says super radical experimentation at
school and then you're supposed to
become more and more boring and then
when you're sufficiently born you get
given responsibility by society to build
something and you promise to make
something safe in the current world you
will be immediately called upon to make
projects and to make designs that are
absolutely not safe that are actually
transgressing and transforming
perceptions and only with this kind of
change only with this kind of radical
experimental posture will that optimism
you have that belief that we could live
in a better society be actually
activated so this is one of the great
experiments the next five six years I
think in the architectural and urban
design professions will be one of the
biggest experiments ever been done which
is to say the university will no longer
be inside the walls of Columbia but will
be operating in a kind of global network
environment so my feeling is and I'm
sorry to tell you this that you're never
going to leave Colombia because while
you were sleeping colombia also expanded
itself to occupy those same 50 countries
where you will operate and we will be
side-by-side with you forever which
means even if you thought that you were
successful in persuading us that you are
more interesting than the teachers this
battle is going to go on for another 20
years and be careful it's a long time
and some of the faculty going to turn
out to be more interesting than you and
it's going to be warfare and we're going
to be with you all of the way we are
unbelievably proud of you maybe this was
never said to you during your time here
but repeatedly over the last two days
faculty have been telling me that this
was the best year ever at the school
this is sort of brutally embarrassing
certainly for the students of last year
it's not good news it's also it's not
terribly good news for the students of
next year either and maybe the faculty
are wrong after all you were the ones
telling us that the faculty are not that
interesting so maybe they're wrong but
they currently think that you are the
best strongest most radical most
unpredictable group that ever went
through the school so it's with just
enormous pride and a sense of total
embarrassment that you've become so good
that I want to you know really express
the affection of your of your teachers
and also to to thank your family for
entrusting us I can only report to your
parents that we were unable to damage
you we tried and there is something of a
feeling in the air and maybe it has
something to do with the crisis of the
last two years in which when almost
every aspect of global society felt
itself to be dislodged from its
assumptions a very radical laboratory
school like like Columbia suddenly has
to as it were elevated level of
responsibility and suddenly a lot of the
ideas that you've been working on seem
urgently necessary and and and and kind
of we're eating to see what will happen
so I think maybe what went on in the
school for you over these last few
semesters was more like the real world
was more like real engagement and
perhaps the next step is the real
radical experiment so it's our sort of
deepest wish that every now and then
you'd let us know what you are doing to
see how this experiment plays out but
again I just want to congratulate you on
an absolutely amazing accomplishment we
would love to claim all of the credit
all of it 110 percent of the credit but
it's completely untrue we admitted you
into the school because you are
certifiably crazy it's no question
instead of going for a series of steady
formulas in a
series of steady answers you said I want
to go to the laboratory I want to go to
the place in which nobody's sure about
the future and I want to participate in
recreating the future so you are
genuinely romantic you are beloved by
your teachers because you're willing to
throw away your life for the possibility
that you would negotiate with the future
I think it used to be that when
universities were formed that
universities were almost designed to
kind of keep the future at a distance
you know universities were about
consolidating established knowledge in
the eighteenth and nineteenth century
was really invented the idea of the
research university we're constructing
new knowledge was the the real paradigm
but even within a research university I
think the school of architecture has
gone to some whole new level of
engagement with the future and I can
only once again tell you how how
touching it is to us that you chose to
come came to come to us to do amazing
work that we're here and will do amazing
work when you when you finish so just
for the first for many times today thank
you and congratulations
and what I just said is true right it's
not just a graduation thing it's
absolutely true that you're dangerous
right that you will change things and
that we want to know what you're going
to do it's very true anyway I would like
to invite in Ricky Walker to come up and
Ricky is he used to be a candidate for
nicest person in the universe but after
he won the award five years in a row
they stopped the competition he's also
quite dangerous not only the nicest
person one of the sharpest brains in our
field absolutely sharp and this
combination of super sweet and super
sharp it's new right it's a new thought
and
you
hold it yeah moxa adeeb
Aras at Berrien Kinnard a key Chaika
fahad al mubarak e
Jawad a tabatabai from Christoval
immunity he also completed the advanced
article research program eleftheria
antonio ducky
jose antonio are aware also completed
the advanced archival research program
go so there are peachy a chinese
Michael Steven Baker
jung kyung pan Mauricio Bianchi
Joyce Emmanuel be here
Jessie cause Blankenship
bianna bogosian
other day I'm castaneda
augustus chong wei chang
esta Z Wing Chun
Yun Seong Chun
marina Cisneros
joseph anthony coursing
Laura Del Pino
brian de luna
a home then
chi wrong thing
Roger Ibrahim dr. bandy
Monica Friday
joseline from a witch
marcos Garcia Rocco
anupama Davey garla
francesco alia janine
Zachary loyal go Stein
Anna andreyevna greeba nova
oliveira Burke
Sarah Maria Gutierrez are mesto
michael anthony holt
Nicholas Aaron Dobson
so some sku
Master Chief Orion Emily page joke he'll
soon june john
in John
1.liga Yoakam chaud
I'm not gonna Johnny
yondu kim coast and east jesus
Nathan Paul fling
sopia cream easy
Norton crotch
kyriakos chiacu
Eric and manual lane
domaine lee Brice Joseph Lee name
Jang Hong Lou
Edwin Lou
neither am i not Laguna
Marissa a newbie arrow pika antoni
London
david michael maple
Eduardo major album solid also completed
an advance of technol research program
Emily and menace layers moment
kakima Kyra casares
porque munoz ivana's
johanna moose Beck
adolfo novel Serrano also completed
architecture advanced research program
shunsuke nakano maximiliano casino
guerra
house though entwistle newness not
Mark's nunez
married a monte Palminteri
le de on park
jung-hoon Park
dube park
Robert Ashley pass off
so hit Tamar up your aura
Miguel cos a lotta yarrow mati on venom
area Foreman
elena paw report
dang dong q
Elise Catherine Renwick
luis enrique de cruz roberto de Silva
Benjamin Robertson Riley Laura Murray
rostrum
show the are owning Vegas odder hashimi
nejad
show d sajjad
Anthony surge Sanchez
ardell do guy from
Aaron some Guillermo Ignacio Savion oh
also competed on total research program
monkey chum
yosh limo
Nikolas tips in
Eric Dunn
chea sweet tongue
Wendy yawen soy give Alejandro revo
quandary spaulder Ravana Montana's Carla
Tatiana vivar y 1
you won Eric Davey Wilson lien whoo
andrew olson
don't roll Jung Ji Young
I have some years don't sit though
rufino Daniel yep
so this is the IAD class of 2010
so now we'd like to invite professor
richard plants who's the director of the
architecture and urban design program to
present the successful candidates for
the degree of Master of Science and
architecture and urban design Richard
okay that's that's right yeah thank you
thanks for being a great class let's
start doing this so de la is wish yes de
la Musa Dagh sire holla alejandra
Asturias darkness ELISA a dealer
manuel alejandro Barrios maybe he test
bhavnagar Aaron bogosian hedgerow Jose
Boris
travis JM bonne nuit Shuang alonso de
got a liat Eisen
Kurt wrongly Franz
Gabrielle Fuentes Milton garavito yummy
hon oops no oh excuse me Marta guerra
past rhian mata Mata also completed the
advanced architectural research program
this year ok jung ji hyung
tiangong Jenny Ellie's Joe say young kim
Bradley David Kingsley yo one quan hai
cockring LOM you lonely
o ye Li jamie-lynn look about Maria Luca
poonam rawat el maana Henry orderlies
Marcus me to matter Maria ma three come
manoj on men co heung-min Candace out of
nine Cynthia Navarro
Sylvia name Sasson noroozi boo talika
panda
hog Patel
Monica penyanyi
Miguel oh my pod us
I'm on a budget sha Joshua Elijah Turner
manas give hottie run Roy Robert Blair
white
young whoo soon hwan young
congratulations
okay we're going to give away a few
prizes starting with the William Kenny
fellows memorial traveling prizes there
a series of different categories the
first category is coming from the
advanced architectural design
subcommittee the first Kenny memorial
traveling prize is going to a project
entitled up in theory in post-war
European avant-garde architecture 1945
to 1961 Lewis Felder abano Montanez
the second goes to a project entitled
beaches in the cities and cities within
the beaches gahanna push back
the third goes to a project entitled
extreme articulation morphology and
tectonics in Western African culture
marcos Casilla aqua and yaki mascara
Casares
and then for a project entitled inner
border must are divided city Olivia Kirk
and for project entitled spectral leonid
off the rican temporizing of a
constructivist project badian pohlman
this is a project about an amazing
architect Vilanova Artigas inspired an
inspirational mutton crop Nick
and now from the architecture and urban
design subcommittee for a project
entitled better city better life ? Ginny
Joe
for future monuments of Istanbul good
friends
investigation of transformation young
cities in new towns in Iran iron
bogosian
for post-construction deconstruction
echo impact of exposed production and
legacies condition um and Cynthia
Navarro
now for the school-wide Kenny awards for
a project entitled Deakin decoding a
hyper density me to mouth off on the
urban design program and Monica pan
johnny from the urban design
and now for a ridiculous project
entitled interviewing Dean's a survey of
the current state of architectural
education Jose arcos
for project entitled shenzhen and the
Pearl River Delta a decade po sleep
great look forward ho chi kar in lamb
a project called the rooms of the
Palazzo one Cristobal I'm gonna take
and the project entitled traffic control
learning conky toes International
Airport's Miguel Perez
and the final Kenny award goes to relay
the American enigma for Sophia chrome in
c and Caracas Korea
why not do another one who do we give it
to let's say Tokyo's Italia bear well in
search of architectural Mongols Jocelyn
from a veg
I think if you listen to the names of
those research projects you understand
what I mean about a new generation with
the whole new capacity and kind of a
density of reflection now we we have the
prizes for the Lucille's miser low and
fish memorial prizes which is just when
each design critic chooses that student
that just impressed them the most and we
starting with the aad low and fish
awards Jeffrey Ann Arbor's studio on
Kazakhstan he couldn't separate arrow
London and eric tan
for those of you who've seen the end of
the exhibition that Studios tattoo
parlor is now available on forty-second
Street and now Jeffrey Johnson's mega
block urban isms marina Cisneros and
Jorge Jorge minus s
Jaime Lerner daniela at will and Trevor
apples wonderful studio in Sao Paulo
entitled contributions to the
sustainable urban development of so
Paulo the winner of the lungfish is
Fausto Nunez
Michael bells studio entitled Paris
Texas the winner of the lawn fish is Ben
Riley
fredricka rats studio on dubai the
winner is jawad alta tubby
Enrique Walker's dictionary of received
ideas to winners max Nunez and marcos
Garcia Rafa
Toro has Ogawa's studio on competing
kaisan the winner is a statue young
Jeff mehnaz studio on contributions to
this is sustainable urban development of
Sao Paulo the actually had a different
name next videos about hyper weather
conditions but the winner is marisa
movie
for reinhard Madden's studio public
housing in Mumbai the winner is Jocelyn
from a veg
galia salomon offs city of god rio
studio the winner is shoddy iranian
now for the urban design low and fish
awards for the critics of Richard plants
Michael Conrad Vanessa Keith Petra Kemp
and Geeta mater there are four winners
Brad Kingsley chirag patel joshua turner
and sun quan young
and for the that was for the studio of
Mumbai hydrologic hydrologic and for
Kingston Jamaica rise n Bay where the
critics were again which it plans
Michael Conrad Vanessa chief petrochem
Pengy tomita again it's a it's a it's a
rock band of Kurt Franz poonam mahina
Henry Matty's and phenomena
and now for the for the early jawad
malik memorial history theory Honor
Award in recognition for the high
quality of work in the history theory
sequence this is award that has a lot of
emotional meaning for the school an
award given by the family of such a
wonderful person that passed away and
the winner this year and upholding the
proud memory of Ali is Jocelyn from a
bitch
and now for a series of honor awards for
excellence in design these this is this
group is the sort of hardcore by far and
away based design group there is so this
is a this is a sort of an obscenely
sophisticated group that is about to
receive these awards the first of whom
is my de enero Laguna
another superstar Sofia cream is e
oliveira cook
and shrimp
and for the first time Jocelyn from a
bitch
bad young Pullman
Marissa newbie
and macos Casilla raho
that's the most honor awards that was
ever given to a single year because the
faculty was so convinced that this
simply was the best year and now for the
urban design program there are three
honor awards for excellence the first
one goes to son Kwan Yin
manas than Barry
Robert White
and now for the visual studies studies
Honor Award for innovative use of
computing media and architectural urban
research design and fabrication the
winner is Bryce the known
you have to understand to win the visual
studies award it's impossible it's
impossible the GC prize for excellence
and urban design to recognize the
student whose work in the urban design
program has been most outstanding so
this is the greatest honor in the
program for Brad Kingsley
and for the greatest honor for the aad
program the William where prize and the
soul Kaplan traveling fellowship William
we're being the founding dean of the
school and so Kaplan a graduate of the
school who endowed the traveling money
that goes with this award and it's to
recognize the student in the aad program
whose work throughout the studio's has
been absolutely outstanding funded by
the request from so Kaplan who graduated
in architecture in 1957 and this prize
is for travel and study following
graduation and the winner this year with
real energy from the faculty max Nunez
so once again this is the class of 2010
aad and aud amazing amazing class
the school turns on food food is over
there it's a little wet between here and
there move fast join your family join
your friends again for myself to the
students thank you so much
you